hey
one
[Music]
you
the next talk I'm delighted to introduce
Paul mallika microsoft research is going
to be speaking on procrastination with
variable present bias thanks and this is
joint work with Nick Robin Brendan
lucier and my student Manila sprint
Arrakis who's on the job market this
year so I'd like to talk about
situations in which agents make
intertemporal trade-offs so you have the
opportunity to encourage some sort of
short term costs in exchange for a
long-term payoff some examples that I'll
use in the course of this talk are
you're a speaker in a workshop like this
one and it's the evening and you can
either prepare your talk or you can go
to the movies so you can incur a
short-term cost which is the effort of
preparing your talk or you can delay it
and go to the movies instead similarly
if your student you could study your
party if you're a marathoner you could
go on a training run or you could sleep
in in the morning if you're a skier you
could like go through all the hassle of
buying skis so that you have them for
the rest of the season or you could just
rent when you go to the slopes this
weekend and in general in all of these
examples you see a scenario in which an
agent is making a sequence of costly
decisions and the costs and options on a
particular day depend on the decisions
they made in previous days so I will
represent this pictorially using what we
call a task graph there's a set of days
on day one is when the task has become
something that you've determined that
you want to complete and on day n plus 1
is the deadline for the task so for
example on day one I've submitted my
abstract I've committed to what talk i'm
going to give and on day n plus 1 is
that I'm supposed to give the talk so I
better have it prepared by then on any
given day you can have one
two states in this graph example so you
could either have your talk undone or
done so you let's imagine you just
prepare it in one sitting and the cost
of comparing your talk maybe it takes
two units of effort whereas the cost of
letting it remain undone there's some
sort of mental anxiety associated with
not having prepped your talk yet so
we'll say that costs you one unit of
effort now clearly if you're an agent
facing this kind of task set up and you
want to take the minimum cost path a
plan of action you would plan on well I
should write the talk on the very first
day as soon as I submit the abstract
that's going to cost me two and that
minimizes the cost that I have to pay to
complete this task on the other hand we
all know anecdotally that what we like
to joke about is that we wait until the
very last night and then we pull an
all-nighter to prepare our talks and
that as you'll notice has a linearly
higher cost than the minimum cost path
in this example um but you know what
really happens although we don't like to
admit it is we are actually slightly
responsible and usually we'll we'll wait
a while and then we kind of get anxious
and in the middle of our period we
decide okay I'm going to do the talk
today and so this is what the actual
path often looks like um so economists
have introduced that model can't be
explained through a rational agents
behavior but economists have introduced
what's called hyperbolic discounting to
explain this type of performance in
which we procrastinate for a while and
then complete a task and a special case
of this hyperbolic discounting which
I'll focus on in this talk is called
present bias discounting in which
individuals inflate the present day
costs by some bias parameter B and when
they evaluate the cost of any plan of
action they're going to calculate that
cost to be B times the costs they incur
today plus the future costs so they're
over waiting the present day
and you can see that this present bias
discounting can account for the type of
procrastination we saw in the
anecdotally likely path of action for
the talk prep example so if your present
bias factors say greater than 2 then
when you're on day one you're looking
well if I prepare the talk today it I
perceive that as having four units of
effort because I've inflated my present
day cost by two whereas if I plan on
doing it tomorrow then i have this two
units of effort which are the mental
anxiety of not having my talk done and
then I pay just to tomorrow which is
also for so if the bias is greater than
2 i'm going to end up planning on doing
my talk tomorrow but of course when
tomorrow comes around i have that same
exact calculation again and I say well
I'll just do it tomorrow again and this
continues until the very last day when
you're only talked a chant the choice is
to prepare the talk and so you prepare
the talk and so you can see that by
having a present bias factor greater
than to you take this anecdotally likely
path and it's linearly higher cost than
the optimal path for present bias less
than two you're just going to prepare
the talk immediately and therefore you
get the optimal cost but notice that for
a generic bias factor this present bias
discounting only makes extreme
predictions and so in this paper we
introduce a per tweak on the model which
we call variable present bias in which
the present bias factor of an agent is
drawn from some iid distribution F at
every point in time so throughout this
talk I'm going to give you a bunch of
examples to illustrate our results and
i'll be using this present bias factor
distribution so with probability one
third the agent wakes up has a present
bias factor of one so they're realistic
about what's going on in their lives and
they they understand
all the future the actual costs of any
path of action i'll call this that they
wake up rational with probability
two-thirds you wake up and you're lazy
and so your present bias factor is
something greater than one let's say
three and as you can see immediately
having a present bias factor like this
will allow for intermediate paths in the
example of preparing a talk because
you're going to procrastinate until you
wake up rational and then you're going
to prepare the talk and so you're going
to procrastinate for some constant
number of days and then prepare the talk
so the question that I'd like to explore
is what is the impact of this
procrastinating behavior on the cost
that the agents incur while they try to
complete some sort of task we will
quantify this using the procrastination
ratio which was introduced in a paper of
Kleinberg in Oran and 2014 which is to
say that the cost of procrastinating is
the ratio of the expected weight of the
path that the agent takes over the
present bias distribution to the weight
of the traverse the weight of the
initial shortest path so what the fully
rational agent would have done and the
main result that I'm going to show in
this talk are some bounds on this
procrastination ratio that are a
function of the structure of the task
graph and the distribution of the
present bias factor all of the results
are going to follow from a main lemma
which I will describe towards the end of
the talk which is that for any
distribution the worst-case task graph
has just to profitless progress levels
so it's going to either remain in the
undone there's just to progress states
you either are done or undone your task
is completed are not completed and
remaining on completed cost zero
remaining completed obviously cost zero
and there's a cost that grows with time
to move from undone to done um
so using that lemma I'm able to derive
some bounds on the procrastination ratio
for certain cost structures on the task
graph yeah so I understand that after
you move along one edge you don't
resample what you do you do resample
everyday you resample so you some days
you wake up lazy and some days you wake
up uh I don't know active I okay and so
I'm going to show some properties of the
weights on the graph that are going to
show that the procrastination ratio is
at most linear like it was in the
leading example in the talk and some
other properties that together with an
assumption that you have a low enough
tendency to procrastinate that is that
your bias factor is close enough to one
often enough then the procrastination
ratio is at most constant okay so
there's a lot of related work especially
in that condom at Khan economics
literature on quasi hyperbolic
discounting which is some generalization
of present bias discounting and in the
cs literature the already mentioned the
Kleinberg and oren paper where they look
at having a fixed bias factor and study
the procrastination ratio of various
task grass for a fixed bias factor and
there's a this work kind of smells like
this flavor of can we introduce
interventions or say structures on the
graph that help people eliminate the
costs so there have been papers that
look at choice reduction like you commit
today to not having options available in
the future which can help you circumvent
the cost of procrastination or delaying
information so there's this really cool
paper by jef feeley about bings or pings
or something what's like all beeps where
you're getting email when you get an
email your computer beeps and that makes
you go check your email but you can have
delayed beeps and that can help you not
waste a lot of time checking email
so it's a really cute paper and then
there's a recent paper that looks at how
agents being sophisticated about their
present bias can impact the
procrastination ratio so in the
remaining 20 minutes I'd like to tell
you a model and statement of the results
and I'm gonna spend most of my time
describing my model and working through
some examples to give you a flavor of
the results and then in the end I'm
going to spend maybe 5 minutes telling
you about the main lemma and how we
prove the main lemma it has a really
cute reduction again I had nothing to do
with it to optimal pricing and so I
think that's it's nice to see optimal
auction theory showing up in other other
areas ok so here's the model in general
form I have a task graph I have some
number of days I need to complete the
task on the n plus first day the task
graph consists of n plus 1 layers being
the progress States I can be at in any
given day in the eyes layer I have a set
of progress states and from each
progress state I can advance in the I
plus first day to some other progress
state and the state's I can advance to
depend on the state I'm at today so
notice I might be able to gain progress
or even lose progress it might not be
possible for me to stay at my same
progress level so this is a general task
graph the weight on an edge is the cost
of going from that state in state you
and day I to state v and day I plus 1
so the agent behavior is going to be
modeled by this present bias discounting
so in each day then the agent is going
to be at some node you and they're going
to draw a bias factor be from the
distribution F and then they're going to
select a plan of action for that day and
move to node V such that that move
minimizes their perceived cost of all
their future actions which is namely B
times the present day cost plus the
future costs and we're going to define
the procrastination ratio as the ratio
between the expected weight of the
Traverse path and the weight of the
initial shortest path so this is the
expectation over this bias factor B yes
their future destiny no there there you
are naive about their future
procrastinating behaviors but the
Kleinberg paper kleinburg at all paper
addresses that in this pasty see uh okay
so as I said my main lemma the workhorse
lemma here is that the worst-case task
graph for any distribution is going to
have this form in which there's just
undone and done states and the cost
grows exponentially so you can think
about this as like a student trying to
complete a homework assignment the
homework is assigned on the day of the
lecture and it's based on the material
for the lecture and every day they
forget a little bit material from the
lecture so the cost of completing the
assignment gets more and more expensive
and so that would have this kind of
structure and so if we for example have
a costume three for completing the
assignment on the first day and it grows
exponentially with this bias factor that
we've been working with you can see that
the expected cost of the student is
going to be well if he completes the
assignment on day I which happens if he
wakes up lazy on the first I minus 1
days and then is rational on the
I stay it's going to cost three to the
eye and so you can see the expected cost
is exponential whereas the optimal cost
was only three to go to it the day it
was a sight so a task graph satisfies
bounded distance this is the first
condition i'm going to introduce to
bound the cost of the paris donation
ratio it satisfies bounded distances if
you can't ever lose progress ok so think
about this as a retirement savings
account where you can always add money
the account is never going to dip
negative right if you don't add money so
so this student homework example was a
non example of that right because from
the first note i had a path the minimum
cost path to the end was just 3 whereas
from some other nodes say this one the
minimum cost path to the end was 27 and
what we can show is that if the task
graph satisfies this bounded distances
property then the procrastination ratio
is linear and this is actually a quite
trivial observation that you can all
reason about why is it true well on
every day and your present day cost is
we are never going to choose to take a
where the present day cost is more than
the total path distance which is bounded
by the initial path distance so every
day you're incurring a cost that's at
most the initial shortest path and hence
you get a linear bound
uh so I want to move on to the next
example which is showing that this
linear bound is tight and this is the
training for a marathon example so in
this example you decide on day one that
you're going to run a marathon and three
months and you have no fitness level
you've never done anything in your life
before and so you're at level one and
you can train and move to level fitness
level two or you can decide not to train
and then there's some epsilon cost and
you stay at level one now on any if
you're ever at an intermediate level you
can just wake up and decide to train in
which case you increase your fitness
level but if you decide to sleep in then
you drop down and you lose fitness by
not training and so that happens until
you reach your peak fitness level at
which point you've decided that you love
exercise so much the training is free
and so every day you can maintain your
peak fitness level for free and finally
on the day of the marathon if you are at
your peak fitness level it's free to run
the marathon but for any other level
it's costly because it's very painful
when you're not fit enough so for this
example the minimum cost training plan
is to like train every day until you get
your peak fitness level and then go
around the marathon but if you think
about the perceived cost of the options
so for an agent with a bias drawn from
our favorite distribution here if the
bias was three on some morning then it's
going to be cheaper for that agent and
you can do the calculation to sleep in
and so they're going to sleep in and as
you can infer by now probably this is
looks like a biased random walk with
some downward drift and therefore if the
and an absorbing stayed at em and
therefore if M your peak fitness level
is high enough you're going to sort of
wiggle around in the intermediate levels
until the day of the marathon and
and spend about n and opt spends just
log in and this example can be improved
to give a tight bound to the bounded
distance theorem okay so I want to
improve upon this i want to get an even
better procrastination ratio with more
assumptions on the problem setting and
so i can what was sort of wrong with
that was that you lost progress in the
marathon training example if you slept
in you are losing progress and that was
what was really hurting you so i'm going
to introduce another property which we
call the monotone distance property
which says that every day you don't lose
progress your your distance to your goal
tomorrow is that most what it was today
and so the marathon example of course
doesn't satisfy this because your
distance to the goal if you don't train
increases and what we are able to show
is that if your task graph satisfies
monotone distances and you're
sufficiently rational so I'm not going
to precisely define what equation we
have for this but there's some condition
you can place on the distribution which
means that it places sufficient mass
near one then the procrastination ratio
is constant and this constant will
depend on the parameterization of your
present bias distribution a sufficient
condition for example is our favorite
distribution in which you have constant
a point mass at one so for example I
here we imagine renting skis and or
buying skis so buying skis is annoying
because you have to like do some
research to figure out what skis to buy
so that has a cost of one whereas
renting skis has a cost of say
two-thirds because you have to go rent
the skis from the rental place and so
the present bias factor 3 is just going
to rent all the time whereas the i/o and
notice this satisfies the monotone
distances you're never losing your
progress
so the guy that has a constant
probability of being rational is going
to have a constant procrastination ratio
so those are the set of results yeah
concepto believed to be one then after
that they even after 1 over p day you
become rational at anything yeah so this
relies on that main lemma that I am
going to discuss next which is that the
worst-case task graph looks something
like this otherwise I mean that that
sort of argument is saying that when you
wake up rational you can make all the
progress you need and so I need to argue
that the worst-case task graph looks
like this and then the theorem follows
rather trivially our parameterization of
the distribution F allows us to see how
it sort of degrades as you become at
this condition holds less stringent lee
so let me talk a little bit about that
lemma which has a really neat connection
to optimal pricing so just to remind you
i'm going to show you that for any
distribution the worst-case task graph
looks something like this notice this
doesn't actually satisfy monotone
distances so for that previous theorem
I'm going to need to reprove this sort
of horse case task graph but it's going
to use the same machinery so I'm just
going to prove it for the graph with no
conditions so
how am I going to construct this
worst-case task graph I'm going to do it
iteratively it every day I i'm going to
consent for every progress state in
layer i I'm going to construct the
progress states in layer i plus 1 and
the weights for the transitions from
layer I to layer I plus 1 and I want to
do this in a way that maximizes the
worst-case procrastination ratio notice
for without loss of generality i can
assume that the distance from s to T is
1 I just can normalize everything by
that and so I'm going to also inherit in
this iterative construction some
constraint that I must satisfy on the
shortest path from today to that goal so
on the very first step i'm going to
start it day one which has only one
progress state by definition as i'm
going to construct the potential
progress gates on day two and I'm going
to have to choose weights such that
there is some path from day one to the
end that had distance one
and the idea is to draw an analogy to
the single agent pricing problem so I
don't have time to go through the
analogy very precisely but I want to
give you some sense some flavor of how
this works and why these problems are
related so in the pricing problem as
shoot you very nicely described we have
a single item that we're trying to sell
to an agent say in the single shot
setting so I'm not worried about a
dynamic mechanism design here and the
agent has a value drawn from a
distribution the auctioneer can set up
some prices so a menu of prices this
would be like I'm going to give you the
item with probability X 1 if you pay me
p 1 if you go i am with probability x 2
if you pay me p 2 and then the buyer is
going to pick an option from this menu
say okay i want the item with
probability three-fourths and i'm
willing to pay you two dollars that's
the thing that maximizes my utility
which is B times the probability I get
the item minus the price I've paid so
that's the pricing problem and it has a
very similar structure to the planning
problem and the fire is equivalent to
the agent in the planning problem the
present bias parameter is like the value
the choices of where to go next the plan
of action today is like choosing an item
from a menu now there's one sort of
thing that's a bit difficult which is
that the objective of the
procrastinating agent is to minimize
some perceived cost whereas the
objective of the buyer and the single
asian pricing problem is to maximize
some utility but a simple transformation
of this objective preserving the optimal
solution we can transform it into a
maximization objective which will end up
having this form and I'm i think i just
x maybe this or something so once you
get to this form you can see that these
two objective functions also look very
similar the value of the
int is the bias parameter the
probability of allocation is the
fraction of distance you cover today and
the price is the fraction of distance
that remains tomorrow so with that
analogy I the note the other thing is
that is the what's the objective in the
of the iterative construction our
objective is to set up this menu or
these choices here in a way that
maximizes the incurred cost of the agent
or maximizes the procrastination ratio
we're trying to construct the worst-case
task graph and the incurred cost is
going to be some linear function of the
weight and the distance parameters and
now we can invoke optimal pricing theory
so Myerson showed that to maximize
revenue there's a menu that you can pick
which has just two options one is don't
receive the item and pay nothing or
receive the item for sure and pay p this
theorem I actually wasn't able to find a
statement of this but you can check that
it's pretty easy to generalize from
maximizing revenue which is just the sum
of the peas to any objective function
that's linear in the peas and the X's
and then the same statement holds so you
can have just two menu items that are
going to maximize your objective and so
we can apply this to our setting in
which what we now can see is that the
worst case when we're trying to figure
out what the continuation of the graph
should look like from node you we only
need to have two menu options one should
correspond to the individual irrational
menu option one should correspond to the
menu option where the agent buys the
item and that's going to once you look
at this analogy here it's going to
result in having some weight here and 0
here 0 here in P times the distance here
so sort of piecing that all together and
there's there's some stitching that you
have to do so
it's not necessarily trivial that you
can stitch them together but because of
the structure of the weights we've
calculated you can stitch them together
and you get a graph that looks like this
so in summary I have to find a special
case of hyperbolic discounting with
variable present bias and that lets us
study agents that procrastinate but
perhaps not indefinitely and then we
looked at conditions that will guarantee
that the procrastination doesn't hurt
the agent too much including bounded
distance which is like you never dig
yourself into a hole so you can't
withdraw more money from your retirement
account than is in there in the first
place or monotone distance you always
make progress towards climbing out of
the hole which is like you're forced to
put some money into your 401 K by your
employer or and that works if you have a
low tendency to procrastinate sumption
that the biases iid indeed round that
seems if I think about the motivating
example with the anxiety like anxiety
increases and how many people the bias
and decreases but just hit just kept up
by edge weights like yeah so that
anxiety i'm using as an edge weight it
is an edge weight in my example so i
guess one question you could ask here is
like what if the edge weights were drawn
from a distribution instead of the bias
factor which so you have a fixed bias
factor but the edge weights are drawn
from a distribution and then i guess if
the distribution is set up correctly our
results will apply but it would need
some sort of Independence which is maybe
where you're objecting yeah that helps I
am I ID
Kira I just wondering if there's been
any work this is on like traversing a
graph that has cost but instead on like
a setting where you have a like fires
have a value with some bias and you're
trying to design mechanisms but maximize
room ya know that's a very interesting
case so the Kleinberg or in paper was uh
I think they'd at least the talks talk
about a setting in which there's the
goal has some value to you and you can
try to traverse the graph and look at
ways to maybe remove edges to make the
more likely that you reach your goal so
the example they like to give is you
know you tell your child that like they
could be Beethoven and that encourages
them to practice piano which helps them
reach the goal of being proficient at
piano which has a lifelong value even
though they never really were able to
reach the stip status of theta yeah let
me show the board cake top graph the
prices of the second menu are growing
expansion so that comes from the
structure of when you apply the meyerson
lemma you're multiplying the remaining
distance by a factor P you have white
people they don't do stuff because the
task may just go away so there's some
chance if you don't like reply to the
email the student will stuff just dies
don't draw a horrible that's that's
interesting I haven't thought about that
I'm I would like to maybe resolve that
by changing the cost on the final layer
like I could have an extra day before
the last day in which every day the
thing
might die so you don't have to deliver
yeah but like I want to add another
progress level which is done which I can
transition to I guess then you want to
transition their probabilistic Lee yeah
I don't know I'd have to think about it
it's actually interesting when you
provide incentives right because then
like the incentive my tits like
administrative work at a university like
it's like the incentives are actually to
wait and maybe yeah yeah Oh humanity
there other questions in the room but I
want to give that time to speak for
lunch so let's not Nicole again
[Applause]